hello miss edna how you doing how are
you oh i'm doing great but you know what
i bet you're doing better you got the
attention of simon cowell oh yeah
but and what about the age difference
you're so old he could give you a heart
attack oh don't worry darcy's signing
those nails now
i was so excited to meet silence he's
just such a hunk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you think your chances are with
simon after tonight
i think my chances are one million
person
pretty flattering i think you blush i
was embarrassed yeah i mean look when an
eight-year-old puppet is singing to you
on live tv there's not much you can say
darcy how you feeling after tonight i'm
feeling great i feel like the audience
and the judges really liked my
bit that i did darcy what would it mean
to win this whole thing um
it would mean the world
that would just be i don't know that'd
be crazy like i can't even imagine that
i love it and to get a win for mel b
you're her golden buzzer i think darcy
lynn really stepped it up she she's just
brilliant i feel like they'll be super
proud of me and i feel like
um
it i feel like it was worth it for her
giving me the golden brother
[Music]